Russia says it has crushed a rare attack
inside its own territory an attack that
originated in northeastern Ukraine two
groups are claiming responsibility for
the raids say they are Russian
volunteers fighting on Ukraine's side
and trying to overthrow President
Vladimir Putin Deborah patta has more
now from Ukraine
[Music]
staring cross-border raids into Bill
garada are the most ambitious attacks
inside Russia to date
video of smoke on the horizon revealed a
battle was taking place
those guns were fired said this Russian
eyewitness then mortars then the sound
of machine guns the Kremlin said
artillery and drones were also used
the boot claiming responsibility the
free Russia Legion are pro-ukrainian
Russian defectors and volunteers who
joined forces with another anti-kremlin
group
social media images captured an unmarked
military helicopter flying low in the
area other video shows armed fighters on
foot inside Russia and a convoy of
military vehicles
last night an alleged drone strike on a
railway station in the region Bill
garage is a military hub for fuel and
ammunition depots
Moscow says destroyed armor personnel
carriers and American-made Humvees were
found at the site of the attack but the
state Department's Matthew Miller said
he was skeptical of the veracity of
reports U.S supplied weapons were used
in The Assault we do not encourage or
enable strikes inside of Russia and
we've made that clear Ukraine was also
quick to distance itself saying the
units acted independently
these attacks unfolded as Ukraine gives
up for a much-anticipated
counter-offensive Ukraine's Military
Intelligence Chief cariello budanov said
this week that they now have enough
weapons Dana for that offensive
all right Deborah thank you